if you have one sort of radical social
justice activist type young person in
the organization they can open eyes
every sort of protection for feeling
harassed or uncomfortable they have on
the books and there's tons of laws like
that I'm Dave Rubin and joining me on
the Rubin report today is an editor at
Reason magazine and the author of the
new book panic attack young radicals in
the age of Trump
Robbie suave welcome to the Rubin report
thank you for having me before we do
anything else here I have a strict
policy that we don't let people on the
show with haier haier and yet you've
come in here with higher hair I'm very
upset I'm so sorry I'm so sorry did you
dress like Jordan Peterson you you
stepped up the action game you got
nothing going on right now I should have
come in sneakers and shorts and t-shirt
which is what I usually do yeah what
kind of libertarian I don't know man I'm
trying to class up the idea of of
libertarianism all right so there's a
ton I want to talk about I really
enjoyed the book here and you you sort
of really get on the inside of a lot of
the ideas that I'm talking about on this
show relative to college campuses and
just sort of the fraying of politics and
all these kind of micro groups on the
left and right that are popping up all
over the place but first off you are an
editor at Reason magazine which is sort
of the libertarian standard is that fair
to say something like that certainly um
wouldn't you become a libertarian so I'm
one of those boring origin stories where
I grew up in like a Republican household
but my parents never really cared about
social issues and we're basically
libertarians without knowing the word
for it and then realized when I found
out basically what libertarianism was
when I went to college that oh yeah
that's me so that's my I pretend I'm
like no my father was born in like a
seasteading platform no no boring boring
origin story just discovered that it was
what fit my views so as people say to me
all the time Dave you're not really a
classical liberal you're not a liberal
anymore you're a libertarian I don't
mind being called a libertarian
obviously but do you see any meaningful
distinction between classical liberal
and Liberty
because this comes up all the time and
I'm curious what the libertarians think
of that I would say not really one of
the things about libertarian classically
liberal people is that the belief in
individual rights is our sort of most
important thing so that tends to I think
the people who are attracted to the
ideas of individual liberty tend to be
against like forming big groups and
coalition's so they start to they start
to that would explain the excess
Libertarian Party I think what exactly
they get skittish when there's too many
other people calling themselves
libertarians ago well I only agree with
that person on ninety-nine point seven
percent of things what about the other
point three percent so then they want to
say well I'm a classical liberal or
libertarian or I'm an individualist
liberal or I'm a I'm an
anarcho-capitalist or say there's a lot
of fraction fracturing that is just what
happens when you have people who are
drawn to the idea of individualism
trying to form a larger group so in a
weird way is that sort of the ultimate
Achilles heel of anyone that cares about
Liberty that to then coordinate around
Liberty I guess the founders were able
to do it somehow and had real
disagreements on exactly what that meant
but sort of in a modern sense when
there's so many different ideas of what
freedom is and now we have 300 some odd
million people that live in this country
but it's really hard to get a unifying
principle I mean that sort of does
explain the naked guy running around at
the libertarian convention I just sort
of the general lunacy because I would
love to see a strong libertarian party
or a classical liberal party saying but
it doesn't seem like like I see no like
Avenue to get there you know any minute
yeah I mean the thing is I think many
people maybe even most people have a lot
of libertarian impulses they want to be
left alone broadly they want to leave
you alone as long as we're not hurting
each other it's fine they like the idea
of the government being small in the
abstract but then when it comes to
specific issues a lot of people don't
necessarily you know connect these
things I go well I want a small
government but all we need Medicare and
we need and you know what about these
other countries we need to make sure
they're doing the right thing so it's
it's the principles not being applied I
think across the board that's what
libertarians are always trying to make
you do apply that same thinking about
this issue where you say yeah it's fine
they can do whatever they want it
doesn't affect me to everything the
government does and then you'll be able
so do you think most of it's just that
people don't think about these issues
that hard because I'm sort of with you
on that but generally when I've talked
to people that say are more progressive
or something when you really get them to
understand like oh you want it so you
will just want to live your life how you
want you want gay people to be treated
okay you want a smoker you want to smoke
the rest of it like actually those are
not things that the government's giving
you the government you just have nothing
to do with them like that there is a way
to get through to them well most exactly
and most people don't spend a lot of
time thinking about public policy in
general or educating themselves about
public policy for very good reasons
because it's pointless they have life
you know they're they're busy becoming
doctors and lawyers and taking care of
their family and providing value to
society the this is an idea that comes
from economics right this is the the
rationally irrational voter the person
who's not well informed about public
policy because there's no reason it
doesn't there's no incentive for you to
become well informed because in the end
of day you only get one vote right so if
you just spend all your time like
educating yourself about this it doesn't
help you that much
is that the the sort of ultimate
Achilles heel then that it's like if
you're a libertarian or you care about
individual liberty granted stuff it's
like if you were gonna find a candidate
that you liked the candidate would
basically be like I don't want anything
to do with you and that's a pretty hard
way to run a campaign and then the
candidate there's no guarantee the
candidate keeps these ideas when they
get into it that's probably well that
seal is that even if you get the right
person in well then the the regulatory
capture of government just turns them
into another they'll be very selective
on a couple issues they'll still talk
about you know the need to protect
individual liberty but then they'll
become a big government crony person on
every other issues not all the time but
it happens most of the time
Rand Paul is pretty good though on this
stuff right yeah he's trying to do it
from within the Republican Party which
Rand Paul has definitely decided that
being a kind of advocate of Trump and
pushing Trump in a libertarian direction
on a few very specific issues most
notably foreign policy is the strategy
he's going to use I think there are I
think there are problems with that
strategy but also good things about it
and he has been I'm glad he's there you
know pushing Trump to be more the thing
I liked most about Trump
it was his foreign-policy was his was
his idea that the Iraq war was a mistake
that we shouldn't be nation-building and
the sort of normal people inside the
Republican Party that never went away
from the previous administration are
trying to push Trump to not do that to
me just kind of another neoconservative
and Rand Paul has been one of the only
people you know kind of in a very
flattering Trump way like hey you're
great don't you remember who everybody
loves you because you're not that right
do you think he's making good headway
there I mean it's still even with some
of the Iran stuff right now like I don't
think we're going to war and I think
there's a lot of big talk but it does
seem to me that Trump is upholding yeah
we're not in a nation build and we're
not you know we're talking to North
Korea yeah I mean if this was Obama
people would be going crazy so there is
some good stuff there there is some good
stuff I wish they could have stopped
Boulton from having any influence of the
administration Pompeyo was more of a
neocon type person but I I'm glad
there's somebody doing it you know Trump
this is one issue where I think his
instincts yeah I just agree with Trump
on a lot of things where I think his
instincts are actually better men's
people around him this is right one
thing well Russ did what he thought was
right on the military dimension of
foreign policy do you think he possibly
puts those guys in like a guy like
Bolton who's thought of as this hawk so
that it seems like you're gonna go to
war at any moment but in actuality it's
like that's the exact reason you don't
go to war you know it's sort of like
this is where his people would be like
oh well that's the 4d chess move you're
right you say that is the 42 but there
is some truth to it if you just if you
keep bringing in all these piece Knicks
well then your enemies know that they
can mess with you where it's like you
bring in a guy like Bolton and it's like
whoa we got Bolton and Trump at it at
any moment they could do something nuts
that could be but I think Trump is just
so much more personality driven than we
all you know we are policy politics
people so and so many in the media do
that they try to think of what's Trump's
doing in terms of just sort of politics
or what political calculus he's making
but I think he makes a lot of decisions
based on who he likes or who he gets
along with it I mean I'm not faulting
that approach either the the just it's
all politics and all policy approach
obviously leads people astray all the
time right so it's just a different kind
of thing where I think he plays it by
ear I think he can be talked into and
out of things
based on the report he has with various
people so and I think that partly
explains what what Rand Paul is doing
possibly to his credit yeah all right
before we get too far into the book yes
you spoke to Congress correct I did and
then something crazy happened you told
Congress that white supremacy is not
completely running rampant that was in
essence
well you said what was the title of the
short it was a Asian that you spoke it
was a subcommittee meeting before the
house of the house civil liberties and
civil rights committee and I discussed
with a number of other panel members the
the ostensible rise in hate crimes and
white nationalism I was brought I was
the one Republican would not not a
Republican but I was brought by the
Republicans to offer some kind of
counter perspective to the the experts
they had who were all talking as if
there is this rise in hate crimes and I
was kind of contextualizing the numbers
you know obviously hate crimes are
terrible and I'm not saying they don't
exist which is exactly what you said to
them but the idea that they are off the
charts higher than they've ever been and
that it directly is because of Trump or
Trump's rhetoric or something it's just
not there's not a lot of good data to
actually support that the FBI is
tracking of hate crimes is actually just
really bad they're counting like 7,000
hate crimes not all agencies report some
agencies that probably do have hate
crimes just report zero it's an optional
reporting thing actually if you go back
to 1996 there are more hate crimes being
reported then just for fewer agencies
than there are now so you know it goes
up it fluctuates it's just not a very
good number we just doesn't really give
us a very impression of anything which
is what I said and actually the other
people who were testifying pretty much
agreed with that I mean this was not
like a fireworks session we had some we
had some disagreements but yeah the
important thing was this was a civil
liberties subcommittee in addition
everything else I just want you know
when we're discussing how to confront
hate crimes hate incidents some things
that actually aren't crimes but are but
it starts to impugn on speech and things
like that
just so we understand if we're creating
like we're empowering the FBI to watch
more people to do that kind of thing
there are civil liberties trade-offs and
we have to be a little we can't just say
rah rah we're gonna fight hate harder we
the government and there's going
and no downsides to that approach
whatsoever that's all I really wanted us
to recognize and probably that's what
happened right we're gonna fight hate
because that's it that sounds like a
winnable fight right you're on hate the
war on hate that's the war we're gonna
fight so the people that were taking the
counter of that though even though
you're saying that privately maybe they
were agreeing with you a little bit or
maybe not that hysterical if you listen
to the media I mean if you listen to
mainstream media it seems that the white
supremacists are everywhere the KKK is
everywhere Westboro Baptist Church and
all of these things were they making any
statistical arguments or was it just
sort of a general you know vague sense
of well we see more of this or there's
more anger on Twitter or something like
that because that seems to be what the
argument is about these days right it's
never about numbers and if you if you
use numbers usually called Nazi well and
they put out numbers that are just
easily abused like the Southern Poverty
Law Center has loved those guys well
right you know they probably consider
Southern Poverty hates it
but they're you know I've looked at
their chart and their chart shows you
know more it's a map of the United
States more hate groups than ever but if
you click on any stage you're gonna see
like okay well how many people are
actually in this group you know maybe
it's like a souvenir shop that sells
confederate memorabilia or something
that that's like two people maybe this
group was four people and they had a
fight and now it's two groups so now
it's mortgage that was before you
looking at I'm looking state-by-state
and in many of these states half of
these groups are actually black
nationalist groups which again I think
present no threat whatsoever there again
nine crazy people yelling it to you at
the street like the like the group that
yelled at the Covington kids in DC just
a lot of black is really right a lot of
wackos out there but that their group
you know increased the certain amount
doesn't doesn't show that there's some
massive spike in hate crimes that kind
of stuff the the a number of groups like
that Pro Jewish groups put out
statistics showing well there's an it
was an increase in maybe anti-semitic
harassment but actually anti-gay her
somatic violence was down and actually
all these threats were made by this one
like crazy teen who lived in Israel this
was the guy who called in the bomb
threats to racism right so that doesn't
okay that's bad and all these things
might be bad
but do not speak to the kind of massive
rise in hate that would be caused by
Trump which is what they're they're
making a political connection there so
to really bring this to a libertarian
place when you go and talk to these
people and Congress has these sort of
meetings and hearings all the time the
people that are listening
well first off it's hard to tell how
many people are actually listening when
when people are talking you know there's
a lot of people on their phones in the
back and the rest of it but like do you
actually think that what you're saying
is getting through to the members of
Congress that are they're like what do
you what is the intention behind okay
you go and you say your piece and that's
nice and it can get clipped and shared
and hopefully some sane people hear it
and then they realize that oh my god the
Nazis aren't coming okay that's fine but
do you think that the members of
Congress that are there are actually
doing anything with this information or
is this just busy work for them it's
like what am I gonna do today I'll sit
on a panel of white supremacy like what
are they doing yeah it's promotion for
them right so they want that clip of
them asking a tough question and looking
very tough on this issue for instance
there was a now now this or now next or
one of those progressive Twitter video
so they took a video of aoc who briefly
chaired this committee actually toward
the end and they had a clip of her
asking this tough quite there was always
perfectly legitimate question she was
saying why do some of these incidents
get that are that have to do with
Islamic extremism get marked terrorism
and these having to do with white
supremacy didn't get marked terrorism
and that actually seems like a perfectly
but the person before her another
Democrat had just asked the same thing
like the exact same thing but she needs
to clip her saying it again I'm not even
faulting the questioning was perfectly
fine again this was a fine hearing but
everyone is just operating I think under
the incentives that now look at me I'm
being tough on this issue this will be
good for me Republicans Democrats it's
the same thing it's not a partisan issue
but yeah these were these were hearings
probably for a for a promotional purpose
for the people holding up right so the
reason actually that I mention all of
this is because so you go up there you
do your thing you lay out some
statistics and you were you did not deny
that racism exists just that just as you
said right here you laid out some pretty
sort of what I would say are just base
level arguments
in the good sense right but then the
Huffington Post decided to go after you
this author at The Huffington Post went
after you implying that you're sort of
denying that hate exists and all of
these things and the reason I mentioned
all of that is because this happened I'm
lady we're gonna mention the guy's name
unless you want to it's not worth it now
but it happens to be the same author at
The Huffington Post who a couple weeks
ago and I invited mayor Pete Budaj
on the show was immediately tweeting at
him to not do my show because you know
I'm a scary evil whatever it is he was
saying about me and I thought these
people the way these guys operate this
these faux journalists that's far more
dangerous than the rise of white
supremacy in America and do my bidding
and in both these instances he's trying
to say that there this this HuffPost
author was trying to say that there
should be no dialogue between these two
people between you and and Budaj and
between me and the other panelists
because it's triggering or makes people
unsafe or it's it's so horrible when
when we would have both in both
situations you would have had a great
conversation you would have learned
mayor Pete would have learned I learned
from listening to the people even though
I didn't agree with them for instance
that thing about classifying some groups
as terrorists and some I didn't know
that before that's kind of interesting I
there might be some legitimate issues
there they'll I had a very nice
conversation with one of the panelists
was of the mother of the woman who died
at Charlottesville of terrible and she
was a lovely woman
very courageous speaker you know we
talked after the far from that the
HuffPost author said how you know how
horrible it was the she he had to sit
anywhere near me this person who's
denying that white supremacy even exist
said it very much exists yeah but we had
a very nice conversation I learned from
her I told her about Reason magazine so
you know difficult conversations and
this wasn't even even a difficult
conversation but conversations between
people with different different
perspectives or a good thing I mean
that's then I have an ideology that's
kind of that right yeah and that's a
very important part of classical
liberalism so it's just it's it's
frustrating and crazy for for me to see
someone like again this author
contending that it's just it's just
wrong on its face or it's dangerous or
it makes it
it's a it's a form of discomfort
bordering on violence which this
conversation which ironically of course
what they're doing is actually
fermenting more of it because if they're
gonna say that a guy like you is too
fringed to talk at a panel like this I
mean that's what that's what they're
doing to me it's like all right if these
two guys are two friends you know it I
mean it's like well then who is left and
they just keep moving but what do you
think more broadly about just sort of
the way journalists are operating there
there are a million examples of HuffPo
and Vox and BuzzFeed and the rest of
them doing this sort of thing taking
sort of mainstream thought or something
that's politically incorrect but but
factually true and an uncomfortable
truth let's say and trying to pin the
people who say it is awful when it's not
their job to do that right guys a
reporter not a columnist right as far as
I know right
Twitter unfortunately or maybe
fortunately has allowed a lot of these
extensively neutral or objective or
straight news writers to reveal or kind
of almost like hello in there unmask
themselves pretty much I try not to you
know paint with a broad brush because
there are people at all of these various
media institutions doing great work and
friends with many of them I like a lot
of what they have to do and even you
know people who get things wrong
sometimes can be right other times so I
try to be a little careful when I you
know characterize the media but you are
seeing a level of I think because Trump
has positioned himself or to some degree
the media has positioned Trump this way
it's Trump versus the media which is
which is a a framing that Trump himself
likes mm-hmm
so then it's its heart you're not no
longer like the like the score keeper or
the referee
if you're the opposing team I mean I'm
making a sports metaphor it's a very
simple I know about two teams and a
referee yeah could have made any
metaphor there you know you want to do
something that fits within your
lifestyle sort of Game of Thrones
okay so you have a so so anyway because
the media is in the oppositional camp
there's a kind of media solidarity or
there's a there's an extra I think
hunger to fight well what's the Trump
there with the anti Trump angle
Noorie and i this is this can be a tough
thing and you know sometimes I agree
with the media sometimes I agree with
the Trump people but even me they're
like well are you on which team are you
in right how do you how do what you're
like with the Covington stuff for
instance that was example of me saying
the the kids that you know and I wrote a
lot about how they had really been the
media had mischaracterize what happened
to them but I'm not saying that from
like like a pro Trump way or anything
and it's just it was hard for both sides
to understand why are you the which team
are you on which is so ironic because I
think that and that's that is
interesting about you because I follow
you on twitter we've met before and I
don't I know what your feelings are on
Liberty let's say and freedom and
individual rights and all that it's but
I don't like that but like I don't know
exactly like I wouldn't say you're a
trump supporter per se or or a sort of
trump derangement syndrome person and
that and I think people sort of think
that about me too and then because of
that you just get it constantly from
from both sides which I guess is means
you're doing something right I have to
believe that alright let's let's shift
to the book a little bit because you
really dope
to the college craziness which obviously
we talk a lot about on this on this show
was there a specific incident that you
were suddenly like holy cow I have to
write the book about that cuz there's
like this endless cascade I mean every
day like that the stuff that happened to
Christakis
and Yale the the the Dean who was
confronted by this sort of mob of
students because his wife had like sent
an email to the campus saying you know
maybe you can wear whatever you want on
Halloween it's not a big deal yeah Jesus
Christ and a couple weeks ago right true
radical this guy that was I think maybe
the galvanizing incident for this sort
of phase of campus sort of political
correctness outrage whatever you want to
call it or the media people in the right
leaning meeting also people in the
mainstream media paying more attention
to this issue you know it's tough what
happened to Weinstein all those things
and you know my question was more than
just you know criticizing these students
which is easy to do and we all do that
trying to understand like like okay but
why are you doing this like what when
did you decide this was a good tactic
for getting what you want hmm
and I sort of through the process of
writing the book kind of increasingly
came to the point of view that they
don't actually see it the way I was
thinking of it is like don't you aren't
you trying to persuade people and you
think this is right they're not thinking
of it in those terms they're thinking of
it in terms of self-defense that if you
are bringing someone to speak on campus
who's going to make people feel
uncomfortable even a small number of
people uncomfortable or you yourself
make people uncomfortable because of
what you think or what you say emotional
or psychological discomfort or is on the
same spectrum of kind of vile of
physical violence of true love true
violence so if you're doing that then
you've engaged in violence even it lets
so even on like libertarian grounds
right you can practice self-defense if
someone attacks you you can you can
fight back you just can't start you
can't start fights that's like the
classically liberal value well they're
saying well you started the fight you
threw the first punch because you
brought this person who makes people
feel unsafe so the the sort of radical
new understanding of safety is at the
heart of so much of the kind of culture
that has changed on care were you able
to figure out what the genesis of that
is like where did that idea really come
from that speech is violence because we
see it all over the place right which
then leads you to oh label someone a
Nazi and then what do you have to do
when you see a Nazi right you punch your
Nazi right campuses are very safe places
actually so at I think to some degree
you mean literally
yes like you're safe from a lot of I
mean even we never had the sexual
assault stuff I read a lot about sexual
assault women who are of the same age
who are not students who are not on
campus or at a higher likelihood of
suffering sexual assault right yeah we
hear all the time there's a rapid EMA
campus right so I think when you have
sort of smaller grievances than the
average population but you have this
immense bureaucracy that is supposed to
be meeting your needs I mean I toured
Arizona State University for this book
beautiful campus
you know very happy place sun shining
every five feet there's a sign saying
are you doing okay did you remember to
breathe today like do the students they
don't know how to breathe like you
should go you're not okay you should go
to the Counseling Center there there's a
perfect trouble breathing very you know
most not all student but these very
privileged people and being told that
there is something wrong with them on a
sort of psychological level and I think
so I think there's an openness to talk
about mental health on campuses that has
gone maybe too far again people who who
need help I'm glad they can get it I'm
glad it's been D stigmatized so that
people can talk about it when they do
need help but there's almost a like you
you want to see something wrong with
yourself because also that now gives you
standing in the activist community
because the intersectionality is the
other kind of big phenomenon I talk the
intellectual phenomenon which holds that
you know the oppressed are the experts
on their own oppression so within a
circle of activist the person who has
the most layers of oppression is going
to be look to for guidance no one else
is allowed to speak on these issues in
fact and considering I'm talking to a
cisgender white heterosexual male right
now this is I know I don't know why you
really got some nerve yeah they're gonna
love this interview to uh really white
men talking about this but so one way to
have some a so if you don't like me if
you don't satisfy any of these
marginalized characteristics but if you
have a sort of mental or emotional issue
if you have trauma if you have PTSD well
that's a marginalized category and
you're sort of being encouraged to see
yourself this way and to kind of look
for something like that I mean I've read
sort of biographies of like
administrator activist type people on
campus where the first thing they tell
you about themselves is that they suffer
from PTSD which again I don't think this
is something you should be ashamed of if
you if you have this you should
absolutely get your help but you know
I've talked to professors who are like
there's no way every single member of my
class at a prestigious liberal arts
university my very wealthy students
actually have PTSD there's no way like
it's just in Paula and when they asked
me for like exam extent
and homework right and things like that
and they're saying it's because I had
PTSD and you said something that
triggered it in class like there's just
no way it's every student but professors
like interested for this book told me
they had that experience so what are the
professors doing because there's always
this sort of chicken and the egg thing
and the inmates are running the asylum
and it's like well who started this is
it the professor's that started this
that are now getting their comeuppance
so this is something I think that
separates me from some of the other
people who talk about this stuff
particularly from the right there's this
idea among conservatives that yeah
professors are brainwashing their
students I think so first first of all
professors are terrified of their
students they're just utterly terrified
of them for good reason because it only
takes one and again I'm not typing when
I the problems I'm talking about it's
not this is not all students like in
most students this is a small fringe
number of students that all of a sudden
have tremendous power
mm-hmm and are getting whatever they
want and it just takes so just takes one
of those in class and you're going to
have a title nine complaint filed
against you if you said anything having
to do with sex or gender again these are
very far left professors getting these
these complaints from their students
because they've sort of rostered this
atmosphere I mean that's the ire you
mentioned Brett lines that before but
that's that's the irony
evergreen basically was thought of as
the most lefty progressive school in the
entire country yeah so you'd think if
those ideas are about you know if those
are truly about diversity and inclusion
and freedom you'd think it would be a
bastion of those things there but these
students are learning it from other
students and they're learning it from
students at other campuses
I guess social media there in facebook
groups together they see what the kids
at Berkeley did or at read or at Oberlin
and the kind of ideas or there's a
there's a vocabulary around activism
there's a you know an appreciation for a
couple older sort of activists here like
Gloria Steinem or someone like that you
know there'll be a picture of her with a
quote shared in a Facebook group that
somehow you know pertains to kind of
their safety activism so they're
learning more from each other I think
than they are they're learning from a
couple professors in some activist
disciplines that have proliferated in
the last thirty years but for the most
part they're really radicalizing each
other did you happen
the video when I was speaking at
university to New Hampshire and like
hundreds of protesters showed up with
noisemakers and they were screaming at
me that's like everything you could have
wrote a book about it but there was a
really interesting moment so that you
know they're shouting me down and they
have noisemakers and they every few
moments they've set up people to chant
and I keep getting right in their face I
mean as close as we are and say you know
they won't look at me right now they
won't look at you because they don't
even want to think you're a human but I
kept saying you know instead of chanting
what you're I'm standing right in front
of you asked me a question but they
won't do any of that stuff but I bring
this up because there was a moment where
an older woman who I don't know if it
was a faculty member or just the local
member of the community something
started screaming that these students
could be killed when they walk out of
here
they could be killed and you don't care
something to that effect and I thought
this is really out of control like not
just the screaming in the rest of it but
the idea that students at the University
of New Hampshire who were all privileged
in the true sense of privilege I don't
care about their skin color or their
gender or their sexuality privilege in
that they're at a great school where you
know you can learn and you know you're
gonna be basically treated okay and all
that but that people are trying to put
the idea in their mind that they're
gonna walk off campus and be slaughtered
and and then they start believing it
right and right that it's a matter of
being killed again they might some
students might have grievances that are
that I would agree with they obviously
have financial because of student loan
all that so I'm I'm starting to
similarly and things like that they're
not literally going to be killed like
that is scaring people and we know as
libertarians when you scare people
that's when you get them fired up to
support like a police state and
government intrusion 'he's that have all
sorts of negative side effects i mean
that was part of the reason i was
pushing back and then subcommittee just
remember when we empower people into
something because people are scared that
has all sorts of negative consequences
for your liberty but I had the same
experience when I I saw Charles Marie
speak at Michigan which is my which is
where I graduated from and yeah there
was a student screaming at him as he
tried tried and failed to speak because
there was no way to do so that that
Charles Marie wanted him dead hmm and
the one thing that sapped kind of the
power of the mob very briefly was when
another student who was a minority stood
and stood up and said well I don't think
I agree with Charles Marie but I'd like
to hear what he has to say I don't know
how I'm supposed to know what he thinks
unless I actually hear this talk and
that was the thing that so then that
then the mob doesn't know how to deal
with that right they're not chat when
they're when they're challenged by
someone else on their side another
student a faculty member something like
that they can stand down in some cases
because they are relying on nobody's
gonna do anything to them you know
because again they're a minority there's
just a small number of people and they
used to do this and then they would stop
because they would get in trouble or the
other students would say would you
please shut up I would like to hear the
person and they would you know the they
they read the room they knew of people
gonna turn on them they're not gonna put
themselves in that position so now it's
the problem has been to last like five
years people are just not doing that
they're letting the the mob shut down
the speaker and they're just afraid to
say anything what do you make of the
self-righteous nature of this the idea
that they walk into these rooms now I
get it they may think that these are
awful people
I won't even sort of besmirched their
intentions right so they think that
they're under attack and all of these
things but what do you make of the
self-righteous nature that they think
that sort of everyone before them was a
bigot a racist or an idiot or a buffoon
or somehow evil but not only that they
also think that all of their equals the
students that they're that are their
equals should be basically silenced
because they don't even have the
opportunity like that kid wanted to hear
the speaker write free speech is a
double right that's actually something
Frederick Douglass said there's it's the
right to be heard as well as the right
to speak I mean all these other students
would probably like to hear this person
again even if they don't agree with the
person one of one of my formative
experiences as an undergraduate was I
was running for the campus paper and I
went to cover an event that Bill Ayers
this radical Weather Underground
domestic terror is whatever you want to
call him he was speaking and I
interviewed him for the paper and I
thought that was so cool I'm
interviewing you know a historical
figure I'm a young person who wants to
be a journalist like that was a really
cool educational experience for me I
mean that doesn't mean you agree with
everything he said well but think it's
like conservatives had been running the
campus that or
our concerns that a dangerous or person
is the exact same thing he makes us feel
unsafe he shouldn't be allowed on campus
and there you know there were Republican
legislators who said it that exact thing
right well he did commit actually acts
of violence though it's a little bit
different but I get I get the point yeah
but but so it's you know it's it's
College you're there to learn from
interesting people you're paying a ton
of money to do it to deprive the other
students of their opportunity to hear
and to speak and to question these
people again an experience that they're
paying an exorbitant amount of money to
have there's just a selfishness to doing
that but again they say we are obligated
because we our people's lives are on the
line and we are protecting people's
safety their emotional comfort is on the
line if they don't feel this is a home
to them and you can't bring this awful
racist person into our home or this
person who some awful racist person
maybe retweeted or quoted once you can't
bring them into our home it's our home
and that's wrong yeah and someone needs
to tell them it's actually not their
home I mean that's what the girl that
was yelling at Nick Christakis kept
saying right this is supposed to be our
home they're our home but no it's
actually not your home it's your place
where you're supposed to everybody does
want to feel comfort on some level right
they comforted comfort is is a natural
you know I'm not gonna bash them for
wanting there to be some like level of
civility maybe but they're not
practicing civility when they do these
things so it's you know they're
screaming at people so and and again
it's not it's not exactly if it's a
public university campus I mean they're
supposed to be in the public square
they're supposed to be uncomfortable
speech people can you know chalk
horrible things about Trump or whoever
the Republican president is they did
that at Michigan when I was there the
crazy homophobic preacher can scream
crazy Westboro Baptist Church like
things in the public square I mean these
used to be things that like the the
progressive ACLU type consensus said
like nope we're gonna allow and these
students completely reject that view and
in fact they hate the ACLU for even once
having it and we'd like them to unhappen
as soon as possible which sort of the
ACLU is kind of flaking on some of these
things at this point right yeah there
there are some real concerns I think the
organization itself is trying to figure
out how it can appease the kind of
progressives that want it to fall to
not hold so tightly to those commitments
and but I think a lot of you would be a
CEO you want told to those commitments
but they just don't know exactly but it
really is in tension with these very
loud even some of the people who work
for them again I the theme of the book
is it only takes one if you have one
sort of radical social justice activist
type young person in the organization
they can open eyes every sort of
protection for feeling harassed or
uncomfortable they have on the books and
there's tons of laws like that title
nine of universities other titles for
for private sector businesses and they
can make it so that you just can't have
difficult or uncomfortable conversations
in the in the college and in the firm
that's why it's so fascinating what's
going on with them because it's like you
guys used to defend everybody's right
all the time you know the Skokie case
obviously is the big one maybe in stress
in her book hate yeah you know it's like
and she's Saturday by the way I'm not
bad no she's incredible but she's not
work she's not working there any hour
and you can see how social justice has
has just sort of infected I mean the
Westboro Baptist Church case I mean
these were people screaming it at
military servicemen who had died for
their kind of screaming horrible things
about them if that speech hate speech is
protected under the First Amendment
everything that the charles murray says
or whatever the students are upset about
is clearly protected when i they also
don't have a very good education about
the First Amendment which isn't just
them that's just the whole country you
know when you quiz people on what nobody
knows for reason maybe for reasons we
discussed earlier in this interview but
so they many of them think hate speech
is already illegal I talk to activists
who said I just want the college to
bring its it's hate speech policy in
line with federal speech law yes it's
already in lost my put in line by not
having not having one yeah and by the
way that's not really what they want
because if they understood what it was
they would that's the last thing that
they want they don't want that exchange
you mentioned universe Arizona State
yeah so I was at Arizona State about a
year year and a half ago I was speaking
there with Michael
from skeptic magazine and I did this
little thing as sometimes I do when I'm
doing stand-up where I just kind of pull
the crowd you know how many
conservatives you hear how many liberals
here progress's well then at the end I
said how many Nazis are here and usually
usually nobody applauds one person in
the back a woman started applauding that
she was a Nazi how so I said to her I
said all right that was kind of
surprising and and everyone's looking at
her and it's all kind of awkward I said
but when we get to the Q&A I will gladly
give you the microphone first and you
can share your nazi thoughts anyway we
do that we do just that and she goes on
and on about how the Holocaust is a hoax
and she and Michael Shermer who's
debunked a lot of these Holocaust
skeptics she asks him some questions and
he just has all the facts and he just
you know smacks her down in a totally
respectful way but sort of puts her in
her place with facts I mention all this
because it turns out that this act this
Nazi was a trans woman which I just
think it's just sort of hilarious in
like just intersectionality beautiful in
just the psychotic Burt way that
intersectionality works or doesn't work
it was a trans woman identifying as a
Nazi and I thought that is real you know
it's funny you mentioned having a Nazi
in your crowd so I in part of the
research I did for this book I found out
that and in 19 it was either 1963 or
1964 the progressive student group at
Berkeley you know this is right after in
the middle of the Berkeley Free Speech
Movement where you have progressive
students and conservative students ever
the students really rising up and saying
no we're gonna have whatever speakers on
campus we want we're do whatever
political organizing we want the
administration can't tell us we can't
that was the Free Speech Movement the
progressive student group was so
committed to free speech that they
invited a member of a Nazi of a member
of a neo-nazi group to campus to speak
not only did they invite him to speak
they all dressed up in full nazi regalia
for it to promote this event was again
and this is in 1963 this was only like
20 years removed from the actual threat
of Nazism versus today and nobody
heckled the guy he would make his
remarks and then they'd laugh at him and
when he was done he went off and that
was that there was no you know there was
no crisis of safety on the can
no one shut him down can you imagine if
they did that today
I mean burn while they already burn the
place down once they re burn it right
but now when we are you know much
further removed from from the threat of
actual Nazism you couldn't you could
never do that and this was the
progressive students who thought it was
important to make a a do a free speech
stunt and B what is the harm from
hearing from a Nazi will learn how
abhorrent and dumb Nazism is yeah you
know if you want a four so winning
Richard Spencer speaking in campus for
instance shutting him down or screaming
at him or getting violent is exactly
what he Congrats exactly what he wants
he gets to say look at the intolerant
left look at what they'll do they're
gonna do this to me they'll do this to
you next if just he gives his remarks to
like an empty stadium or like three
actual Nazis there that's an that's
probably bear Assange for him you don't
like don't show up with a violet you're
playing into their hands yeah let's talk
about some of the sort of subgroups that
go on in this because you know we always
talk about sort of the left and the
right and it does seem like it's coming
more of an the left these days but what
give me some of the just the subgroups
on each side that are bubbling up sure
so I did a lot of work on since I read
about sexual harassment and sexual
assault and the title nine stuff on
campus one of my chapters is about title
nine related activism fourth wave
feminism and what has happened on campus
because of them that's a chapter that I
care a lot about because I write a lot
about that when you were writing this
title nine was still in it yes right
this is the only one that has sort of a
there's a good news resolution that and
again I disagree with a lot of things
the top administration does but Betsy
DeVos the Secretary of Education changed
the guidance related to title nine in a
way that I absolutely applaud so this is
this is a federal statute from the 70s
it's one sentence long it's attached to
the law that funds higher ed the L
education funds all education if you get
federal funds for your school you have
to you can't discriminate on the basis
of sex or on the basis of gender that's
all it says perfect that's perfectly
benign it was intended you know if you
have a male sports team and there's
comparative
interest in having a you know you don't
have to have a girl sports team if no
one wants to play but if you have people
who want to play you have to fund that
team dude you're not gonna force women
to play football but enough of them show
up well I mean we were probably getting
to that but originally nineteen
seventies that was not what was going on
yeah under the Obama administration the
assistant secretary the bureaucrat under
this who is charged with making sure
universities are complying with title
nine started interpreting it much more
broadly to include her harassment and
sexual assault and they were defining
these terms so broadly that sort of
anything that made someone feel feel
uncomfortable for a reason of sex or
gender could be considered a title nine
problem now it wouldn't actually be if
you brought this before court or
something that that wouldn't happen but
universities are compliance places so if
you have this big government bureaucracy
telling you well we kind of think you
should do it this way you're not gonna
fight him you're gonna you're gonna roll
over so they rolled over in ways that
were just disastrous for free speech
because again speech related to sex and
gender they're saying well if you're
making people uncomfortable for that
reason it violates the federal law and
also a due process so when there is a
student accused of sexual misconduct
they were saying well we would like you
to adjudicate this under this standard
and we really don't want you to have any
like cross examination at the hearing
and we don't want you do any of these
other things so they were they were
literally obliterating due process they
really were for I mean there have been a
hundred lawsuits brought by student
usually male students often athletes
often male students of color by the way
or immigrants again the normal issues in
the criminal justice system where black
people get arrested more for things
totally true in the university
bureaucracy as well the students sued
for saying I was I was wrongfully
accused or regardless of whether it was
wrongful or not you violated my rights
in a due process sense and they and when
it goes to court they win and then they
sue the universe the university's work
just caught cuz they're like well the
government is going to yank our funding
if we don't do it the way they say but
we're gonna get sued and lose because
this is ridiculous this is a farce and
this was all because of this this
guidance from the Obama administration
but then it was
so the activist component is activists
the guidance comes out in 2011 sort of
feminist activists on campus I think
started quickly realized within a few
years of that that title nine now was
this great tool for adjudicating
grievances or for punishing people who
engaged in speech the way you didn't
like I mean there's literally an
activist group where the leaders of it
got the numeral nine tattooed to their
ankles because that is how important
this interpretation has been to to
feminist activism and they said Laura
Kipnis he's probably someone you're
familiar with you as a pastor but I
there's all these cases there are cases
that we're never famous you know where
someone just got like an F on their on
their exam because they wrote the name
of their instructor wrong on it and
someone said you wrote well that's a
pornographic actresses name so you
intended this as a sexual slur so so the
and and the professor exercise so we're
concerned this would violate title nine
again it wouldn't right it's not what
the statute means right no corraled
agree with you but and what about those
two kids were there there was the one
case the two college students guy and a
girl that were hooking up and then they
both went after each other for a title
nine because they were basically trying
to preempt each other yes that's that
started becoming like legitimately a
thing if you had a sort of sketchy
sexual encounter which is the case in
many of these they disciplined all right
this isn't you know someone broke into
your dorm room and and you were like
hold held their pan over your mouth this
is we were drunk we were doing drugs
it began consensually or we sort of
intended to do something and I don't
remember what happened now I'm
uncomfortable about it and and maybe
something bad or violence and policy did
happen I mean these are hard to
adjudicate anyway right because they
were lying and hazy alcohol is a factor
in the overwhelming majority of these
cases mm-hmm
so but so then you wake up from this
encounter and the first reporter has a
huge advantage to these title nine cases
so the I saw I was trying to see cases
where you had the male go to the title
nine office first to accuse the woman
just to pretend that she would do it
you know I saw cases where I we're a
fleeting kiss
became a title and is you where the
normal just human courtship again I'm
not I'm not saying sexual assault it's
not a bit it's not a problem on campuses
or wherever else but things that should
not have been handled by campus
authorities we're being handled by
campus authorities things that might
have been regrettable or bad or some or
maybe they should learn you know don't
drink so much into the male and the
female lessons are not being learned
this is immediately going to sort of a
criminal matter that that can just that
can destroy people's lives on both sides
I mean to get expelled from college for
rape I mean that is a huge financial
like hit that you're gonna take never
having a trial for rape lawyer I mean
these policy said you couldn't have a
lawyer there one of the things DeVoss
has done is said yes there has to be
there has to be a lawyer there the
student wants a lawyer who can ask
questions of the other side you don't
have to have the man and the girl and
questioning each other but you have to
have at least questions interchange I
mean at some of these hearings you were
having not even panels they were setting
to get away with do away with panels
where it was one administrator was
investigating the case was deciding
which witnesses to just to talk to there
was a there was a case where the the
accused a again a male black football
player said well what can you interview
like all these people who know including
one time the the victim because she had
not filed a complaint they were like
dating and it was someone else who
didn't like their relationship so this
person filed a complaint so a third
party could file a complaint it that is
obligated to if they became
knowledgeable of alleged or suspected or
possible violation of title now that is
22 yeah I'm watching there's a hulu
mini-series on it right now I'm watching
it it's great it's exactly that so so
you had cases where again there's no
actual dispute and they're being
adjudicated and I got expelled the you
know the administrator would not talk
would not interview the people who knew
this is all nonsense he said no it's my
job to determine who I speak with and
then you can't and then he public rates
a report he wasn't even he wasn't even
recording
interviews he was just it was just his
recollection of who we talked to and
this is a standard practice across the
board for the single investigator model
which was becoming very important and
then the new guidance has gotten rid of
thank God yeah man that is some evil
stuff so it I find this the title nine
stuff so interesting on so many levels
because there's sort of this social
justice level there's a legal level
there's a there's a sort of fundamental
sort of classically liberal due process
yeah if you're accused of something you
you should be able to defend yourself
and use all the powers of the law that
would allow you to do that yes but the
other part that I think is interesting
is I remember when DeVos reversed all of
these things that you're laying out of
why they're so wrong I remember the the
you know blue cheque celebrity
Twitterati and the bell the Bette
Midler's and Sarah Silverman's and the
the progressives on Twitter basically
all say Trump hates women he's Pro rape
all of these things and it's like and
then you look and it's like well these
things get fifty thousand retweets and
eighty thousand retweets and it all
sounds right Trump's removing
protections from rape victims and it's
like I better scream about that it
sounds right and they never want to hear
any of the things you just said the
uncomfortable truth right you laid out
there and breaking that well it's very
similar to breaking the the white
supremacy argument that you're trying to
break is yeah they don't want to hear I
mean complicated narratives are less
sexy for reporting they don't want to
hear that actually this is kind of a
problem and anyone who's like studied
this you know this issue in any
seriousness knows that the existing
system just wasn't working and again
like I was saying it was causing
lawsuits from both sides and the
universities cannot handle this under
that you know that's like a complicated
thing the nope this is an further
evidence that the administration is
waging its war on women that isn't
easier sort of headline so much of the
reporting when DeVos changed this stuff
was just was just it was clear they
hadn't even read what the new guidance
was going to be in their defense it was
very long I guess but there it was
completely disconnected so I saw some
journal it there's a journalist at Slate
actually who's covered these things a
little better and he was saying and he
when he wrote about he's like yeah this
was actually there were some problems
here I don't know if the new approach is
better but like there was this was not
exactly working people would start
the problem a little bit more closely
knew that but the activists I mean the
activists knew that but they wanted it
to still be the other way because they
they did not take the like enlightenment
liberal view that these people deserve
due process they think it would be
better you know if if everyone is
expelled even if you know half of them
are innocent as long as long as we got
the other half which is just like a
total inversion right of kind of the
Enlightenment principle that it's better
you know that guilty men go free than to
put away even one innocent person that's
like the the bedrock of our classically
liberal Western understanding of justice
and they were just they were utterly
against and they'd say well you know
we're not sending these people to jail
their lives making them unemployable
forever yeah but yeah yeah so what what
are some of the other sort of subgroups
that you dive into here because the
fascinating thing I thought was there
because of the way the internet is and
message boards and message boards are
people are message boards whatever
whatever these little groups are and
telegram and all of these everything
that all of these little niche very very
niche groups that often have these
competing interests they're all popping
up and it's hard to really it's hard to
gather and I talk about this like how
much actual influence they have how much
momentum they have what they're really
trying to do how much of it is just
purely trolling and just trying to turn
things and all that well I'll talk about
the one that's actually doing the best
right now which is the democratic
socialists of America unlike many of the
other groups
I studied they are highly organized they
had clearly had a lot of people in them
and they're and they're poised to have a
big mean they're having a political
impact they I can't underestimate or
overstate rather their dramatic increase
in the last few years I looked at some
of the numbers for these groups of this
group this is the far left economic
Bernie Sanders esque group yeah that was
just a bunch of old hippies I'd like
there were a couple thousand of them
from you know from when the group
started in the late 70s or 80s or
whenever it was up until three years ago
it was the same people nothing had
changed they've gotten thirty years
older yeah but they had not added a
single new member or had a single new
subscription for their for their
publications in the last three years the
average age of one of their members has
dropped from like ninety thousand to
thirty these are highly motivated young
people who who are passionate about
socialism we talk a lot about cultural
issues but what animates them is the
economics the the economic inequality I
interviewed people who said things like
you know capitalism is the most evil
system ever devised and we're gonna
convince people that socialism is good
that their private university holding a
knife oh right right right right
and they but and but they also hate
something that makes them similar to
some of the other groups again they hate
liberalism broadly they hate sort of
moderate liberalism like the the Normie
Normie 's right they hate the just and
that's everyone from like Hillary
Clinton to me in the spectrum people who
like broadly like free trade in markets
and stuff I guess yeah we're all the
same we're all just normal Ibrahim I
self in that to probably they hate us
more in a way than they hate the
Conservatives right there because
there's like because they think we're
sort of faking it or something like that
well and Trump is weird for them because
while Trump you know is like the most
hey table for a lot of these other
intersectionality groups for sort of
like cultural reasons and things he says
about immigrants women so on for them
you know they actually share some of
like the trade dis not liking and just
kind of dislike a business that
occasionally Trump has sort of you know
kind of addressed or talked about that
that makes also they think the rush of
stuff is stupid because they kind of
like Russia probably for they admired
sort of communism or something like that
right so it's it's actually weird to see
them not as worked up about Trump in the
exact say I don't say they're they're
not pro Trump at all they still hate him
but but they hate they hate Democrats
liberals neo liberals who are like
squishy and like markets sometime and
are not radical enough you know they
don't want Joe Biden is just as bad as
anyone else it's Bernie may be Warren no
one else everyone else is equally is
is tainted by the same original sin of
liberalism do you think there is any
chance any chance whatsoever that the
modern Democratic Party not that I have
any love for the modern Democratic Party
but can it can the shell of that thing
survive this or are they going to
completely dismantle any remaining
liberal and and JFK will be will be
you know his memory will be destroyed -
in the course of all that that goes
they'll have to well here's some moment
some moment for hope I think it's going
to be a lot harder for them to do this
then maybe they expect right now they're
riding high on victory they got a Ossie
in there you know Bernie's really
popular they they think it's their
moment you know moments don't often last
as long as the people who are here and
some of them think they're gonna have a
lot more difficulty sort of just
convincing you're just sort of regular
older maybe even religiously inclined
normal sort of Midwest rest of America
Democrat not not Republic Democrat a lot
of those right so they're gonna have
trouble getting the people that are
constantly saying or harm the people who
just like Biden yeah there are a lot of
people out there who just like him
because he was a vice president he and
again people who are not as motivated to
know every detail of policy the way your
activist woke set is right but I guess
my question is do you think so let's say
I mean conventional thinking if you just
look at the polls and I hate polls but
it's basically like Biden is is crushing
it right yeah he's up by 2030 points
over over Bernie and most of the polls
and maybe to your point Bernie already
peaked four years ago so maybe it's
already over but that they will have to
destroy him that it will cause such a
rupture in the party that I that it may
be what the natural entropy of it is is
that the party actually does have to
split into and I think there's a version
of this for conservatives and
Republicans as well this is this is a
this fracturing taking place on both
sides is very interesting right now
because yes Republicans as well are kind
of breaking into this more populist tea
in the vein of Trump versus I'm sure
you've seen some of this fighting
between National Review and first things
people over a more kind of libertarian I
mean lightly libertarian not even this
libertarian as I am version of the
Republican Party that maybe
existed I'm enjoying watching that fight
very exactly because it's it's David
French and Sora Amar'e Amar'e yeah and
I've been watching it going this is how
an intellectual fights both uh but you
guys are fighting for the heart of what
you think conservatism is supposed to be
and it's basically being done
respectfully and I think they're gonna
sit down I'd be happy to host it here
it's like it's like wow there's
something cool going on there but that's
not how the fight is going down on the
other side yeah I mean I do see
similarities though because again it's
because one of the sides sees itself is
ascendant they think their political
moment has arrived and maybe it has I
mean maybe both of these things could go
the direction of you're gonna have a
more nationalist trade and immigrants
skeptical you already have an immigrant
skeptical but also very trade skeptical
of Republican Party and you're going to
have a sort of much further left
socialist inclined Democratic Party the
way you have in Europe the problem is
with the American system we like because
of the way we're device we always just
have the two parties whereas in Europe
you can have both of these parties and
then a spectrum of more libertarian or
more centrist or more moderate parties I
think it would help it have that we
can't or do you think the system is
right but do you think if we had a
little more of a coalition based system
where people because the idea that these
broad blankets have left or right public
concern it doesn't really fit anymore do
you think a coalition system might I
mean they've got all sorts of problems
because the coalition's because this
tiny parties have absurd power you can
take out anybody at any time I'm always
skeptical that any kind of the tweaks to
how the system of votes are tallied will
ever translate to anything being better
for what I want but yes I would I would
prefer if sort of libertarian inclined
people could ally with certain groups on
select issues but like maintain our own
identity and right now it's just you
have to fall under the umbrella of one
or the other which is frustrating cuz
we're at a moment where I think both
parties are moving away from I mean
that's part of the theme of that I
talked about in the book the meeting of
the extremes and then there's a
radicalizing taking place on on both
obviously on campus
and in social media we see the influence
of the left but I try not to you know
again I don't want to overstate you
campus and Twitter are not the whole
world the Republicans have control of
government so you think there's a way
you can maybe split the difference
there's nothing like one idea that sort
of makes sense to me is like because I
would love a somewhat functional
libertarian party but you know that if
if a [ __ ] if a libertarian party got in
and got five percent which they never
get five five my god it would be it
would be incredible but you know what
would happen of course it would lead to
probably president Bernie or something
like that so I don't want that so the
idea may be that what if you had
something where you could vote for the
whatever a third party you want and then
once the the three percent checks in so
there's the election now three percent
checks in and now you know they're not
going to do anything with that three
percent that then they could decide
where they're gonna give their support
so that people could at least still feel
good about the original vote does that
make sense something like that yeah I'm
just trying because so many people are
gonna be disgusted at what they have to
do at the next election and they were
already discussed in last time and I
think the more we keep having to be
disgusted just the more people will just
check out yeah politics is is by its
very nature disgusting right we're
deciding which policies the entire
country all 300 or 400 million people
are going to have to live under which
you know which tyrant will be oppressing
them on which things we because we have
a just sort of unitary system where the
executive gets to do everything Congress
has delegated all its authority to the
president whoever view whoever the
president is not to Trump but to the
office of the president yeah so they're
always happy to take more to that power
yeah yeah and comment Congress has been
having yeah you can decide they don't
even Congress doesn't even weigh in when
we're like declaring war they're like no
you get to I can choose who we bomb we
don't really care which is and actually
I think the Supreme Court has in some
state in some sense stood up and is
playing a role of Congress by almost
adjudicating policy more directly then
maybe they were intended to do because
there's just no body Department like
separate from the president from the
Office of the President Congress is just
a is just a is just a rubber stamp but
again and we have this big country where
these rules will be for everyone people
who live in Florida people who live in
fornia people who live in Iowa and
Michigan all have to listen to even
though we have different values and
might care about different things
because of this just immense central
government which is not the way it was
intended to be and makes us all mad at
each other on Twitter and everywhere
else
let's decentralize the whole damn thing
yes I've thoroughly enjoyed this
conversation Robi thank you my feel I'm
still alert about the haier haier beyond
that it was pretty best to meet your
issue in the election lower hair for
more on Robi follow him on twitter at
robbie suave
[Music]